the
establishment i don't know what term to
use the blob the ruling class the regime
they have done everything they can to
prevent anyone from questioning the
narrative whatsoever i'll give you an
example of this i got a notification on
my instagram over the weekend that gina
carano had had tagged me in an instagram
story
he said oh that's gray you know gina
carano this terrific movie tv star now
is doing a movie with the daily wire so
i look and it was just a little video of
me making fun of dr fauci i wasn't
really making any claims and no
scientific or political claims i was
just kind of doing my deck to fouchy
voice and making fun of what a jerky is
right so that's all that it was and it
was her posting and saying like ha ha
this is funny
so i tried to repost it but i couldn't
because there was a big warning label on
this video of me making fun of fabchi's
voice and it said quote for covet
information you've got to go to the blah
blah blah blah blah i said well i'm not
i'm not expressing any coveted
information here i'm just making fun of
this jerk in the public health
establishment
so okay i go i kind of do a work around
i go into my inbox i find the story i
share it to my my
own page and then
a few hours later i went back to look at
it i wanted to see how many people had
seen it you know you get these you get
these analytics from instagram so i
looked
and i had shared two things to instagram
at the very same time the first thing i
shared had been seen by a little over 8
000 people
that that had come from a
very small account then i shared gina's
story
that had been seen by 58 people that is
an impossibly small number what it says
to me is something we probably all
inferred for a long time which is that
if you you see something on instagram
with that warning label covid
misinformation it's just not being [ __ ]
it's being shared to so very few people
that for all intents and purposes it's
not going up and the
oligarchy the in this case using
uh big tech as a proxy
is going is willing to do that even on
jokes even on jokes about the high
priests of
the regime then also on instagram
try searching for
natural immunity as a hashtag so we we
all know natural immunity is a thing by
the way i don't want to be accused of
spreading misinformation even the public
health establishment even dr fauci is
acknowledging there is such a thing as
natural immunity but it's taken a very
long time for them to do that and
they're really trying to downplay it if
you search hashtag natural immunity on
instagram it won't come up the nearest
thing is someone who wrote hashtag
natural immunity with a middle finger
emoji
because big tech is censoring this stuff
they don't want
any of this information getting out okay
well
explain to me then
why it is
that the fda is holding off on booster
shots for americans before you say it
let me i want to cut off the liberal
critics at their knees
they'll probably say well no michael
it's just a technical issue you see
because they didn't have enough data and
what don't worry the next time he goes
up for a vote it's going to pass and
this okay i'm not asking about any of
that i'm not asking about any of the
scientific data here
i'm asking why if it is so obviously
common sense that the vaccine is 100
safe and 100 effective
the fda wouldn't approve it for
everybody
obviously because they had questions
about the safety of the vaccine for
people under 65 for the vast majority of
americans
and as for the effectiveness the very
fact that you need the booster shot
shows you that the vaccine is much less
effective than we were told that it is
i'm so glad you liked that clip if you
wouldn't mind leave me a comment here on
youtube subscribe but more importantly
go to apple podcast spotify stitch or
google play wherever you get your
podcasts type in the michael knowles
show click that beautiful little
subscribe button maybe leave a five-star
review if you're feeling generous we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you